a local shop specializing in witchcraft
and the like is part of the craze is
drawing attention to lake mead blasphemy
boutique now selling what it calls lake
mead corpse water of course this comes
just two weeks after two bodies were
uncovered because of low water levels
the water is not actually from lake mead
and it's not real corpse water though
that is something used in witchcraft the
shop owner says the bottles are meant to
get people interested in southern nevada
history
we all have heard the rumors of bodies
being dumped in lake mead by the mob
back in the day and i'm sure there's
other people that dump bodies there just
like most lakes
but for the most part
i think that our history can lend some
learning in this day and age
again this is not real corpse water not
from lake mead it's only for
entertainment they say staff say it's a
mix of water the plant witch hazel rocks
and dirt you can buy it from the shop
near rainbow and oaky priced at 7.77
they're just having some fun interesting
and lighting up a situation yeah so
that's that's what we do in our business
right
you got to keep laughing
you want some pollen water
you want some mulberry water
we don't i got to tell you ted i have
found the lack of winds the past what 4